[Music]
welcome back to off the record
where we talk about whatever
where is everybody they're all gone we
got a special series today
and it's called two daddies and a baby
but you gotta figure out who the baby is
and where the two daddies are
i don't have a kid i don't have a kitty
oh i don't have a kid and john here
hello that's his name it's our mascot
our just kidding news mascot
where you could get the sweater actually
but only for pet your honors that's true
so a lot of people might be wondering
why the hell
is it only three of you guys this dude
had to go ahead and get [ __ ] corona
i know i don't know actually i don't
actually know how i got it from because
you know like the last six months
um i feel like everyone kind of went
through the same thing like right when
the quarantine and corona hit like
everyone's really strict
in uh february march-ish right yeah i
remember even
when i came back from the grocery store
i'd go like this
hand sanitize everything take wipes out
even wipe down the plastic bags
and then you know i think like over the
months though god damn that's loud
over the months though like everyone
starts to get more relaxed right like
before
we didn't see anyone outside of our
household then people start getting
like haircuts or car washes or whatever
you start seeing more and more people
the last three months i feel like i got
a pretty good routine going on where
it's the same
jk barbell our food group friends and
then it was going good
and then i feel like maybe from a
thanksgiving dinner we saw some extended
family that we haven't seen before
wait were they positive is that a lot of
them i guess are essential workers
so they see way more people than even
like for us we might see our household
and then the same jk barbara people
but they see the world yeah because
between us three
yeah i should have been the one that got
it because you're all over the world
yeah during this whole time like i went
to the east coast like i was in colorado
and all that but then
like when i go to these places i'm not
actually
in the city i'm just like when i go to
the east coast i'm in the farm or
something
you're also relatively safe too i'm
seeing the same people
basically and you didn't do anything
dumb either it was just like
one mistake which was kind of like bound
to happen to some people
you know yeah it's not like you go out
asking for it and you get it yeah even
though that's how you kind of like
i did i mean like i asked for it so like
when i when i was begging for it
all year it's from a dumb point of view
where it's like
i don't want to see doom far away yeah
so it's kind of like
just hit me with it already you know but
you're not going out like coughing my
mouth no no no no no
i'm gonna be safe but if it happens i'd
rather it happen sooner outside the
hospital
hey throw your needles here but you're
not like doing it in a dumb way but
that's the thing like my routine hasn't
changed much
it's this gym we all wear masks i go
home
that's it but you were at risk though
right like you you you have people
around you that you're just like oh [ __ ]
and then you had to run away from them
yeah but they all tested like it was
like false positives and stuff like that
they got like multiple things and it was
it was weird where
uh they would take like well like one of
my roommates had like a slight cough
and then he got tested positive so we
all quarantined we all got tested a few
days later
uh just to make sure it wasn't like
right after and like obviously we can't
catch it like the next day
um or like be testing positive but then
he took like multiple tests after it all
came back negative negative and then
even now he like takes like the antibody
test and never had it
damn yeah the tests uh are more accurate
now too in the beginning yeah in the
beginning there's so many false
negatives and false positives
but now uh all the tests that they have
now i think what they're saying is
because i was talking to my cousin who's
in medical school right now and he was
saying
that the tests it still can have a false
negative
but if any test says you're positive you
just need to go quarantine immediately
yeah
really yeah damn so it's like the
chances of it being fall and i was
reading like the fine print behind it's
actually really weird
how the tests work it's not like an
actual like [ __ ]
you test someone and then it's yes or no
answer it's actually
the chances of you having it in relation
to
the population what does that mean so
like the what they're testing for
isn't like okay this will [ __ ] took
cocaine before like you're looking for
like cocaine metabolites
what they're looking for is like things
that recognize the virus but as we all
get the virus together
the chances of like virus like particles
or rna or whatever
it increases oh so it's actually
comparing the amount that you have
to what the population has so that's why
like it actually like adjusts
so how can they dictate that from like
the regular flute
the strain yeah like the virus each one
has its own like
quote-unquote fingerprint got it yeah
but
yeah because the way i understood like
disease and virus and things like that
is it's always around us but our immune
system
is what lets it come in or whatever
that's what's protecting us
yeah so like if you have a weaker immune
system then you're more susceptible to
getting like the severe case but i think
with this
it's uh i'm sure it's based off an
immune system in terms of how it affects
you
i'm sure we all have a like an equal
chance of catching it say we're all like
kissing someone that does have it and
like 10 of us kiss the same person right
but in terms of how it affects people
because i've had people that were like
no signs no nothing they just tested
positively quarantined i've had
other people that were telling me that
and this like close people to them that
they were literally like on the brink of
death and
younger yeah worst case scenario is
death especially if you got pre-existing
conditions or whatever it's like
that's what sucks because like yeah like
my buddy he just had a
sore throat and he's like yeah and then
i quarantined for like two day
two weeks and then he's like for two
days he felt weird and that was it
i was talking to tim this is kind of
weird
so for me i had maybe a slight fever the
first day and then after that i was gone
um and then after two days i was pretty
much at 80 percent
and then it was just slowly getting
better he told me for about a week now
the fever is on and off it's like what
101
98. 102.99 and it's just like and he
lost taste too
what and i was like damn that's crazy
i'm gonna do i was like
i wrote about him i was like did you
finally write your movie now because he
has nothing to do and he goes no but
he's been killing it on all the pr stuff
like
uh doing radio talk uh radio interviews
and talk show interviews
because all online for his new uh yeah
tv show we had a
uh the vlog that went out a few days ago
and in the vlog
tim text you basically to set up a
meeting and some people were like what
the [ __ ] i thought they were both
quarantining but other people were like
no it obviously means that lilly just
set up a time to chat online oh my god
that's so stupid
i was gonna bring it up i was like if so
say tim he has this baby
i wouldn't like during these times i
wouldn't let up until like a year
until like this vaccine's over anyone
seen my kid if i had a baby now during
these times
because i've heard cases where like
everyone says and people are still like
i don't know why they invite them over
anyway but they're like just don't touch
it don't like have to like pinch my
baby's cheeks
don't give my baby kisses um i would
just be like just don't come over in
general
sick kids are hard to take care of man
like even with tiger when we got him
tested
so he tested negative but like you know
kids they don't know what's good for
them
so even giving them like nyquil
but then they keep coughing all night
i'm like dude you need this thing it's
gonna help that's why i gotta get them
that pink [ __ ] dude
i would drink that if they bottle that
like in a drink form i will drink it
like this yeah
they do pepperoni yeah we give them the
fresh it's good bro put on ice
no you can't drink it like now we give
them the cherry whatever
and he doesn't like it that's gross man
i know i don't know you can't do that
have they like updated the flavors
there's only like cherry or grape from
what i've seen that tastes
like oh it's so bad yeah i think they
would have been able to mask it by now
but when we got uh taika the test
um we had to trick him because he sees
like he was sitting here
in jill's lap and the doctor had that
little brush thing to stick in his nose
then you could already see him going
like what the [ __ ] is this there's no
other way for kids
even they do the same oh no they're
gonna hate it i know we're like oh this
help cleans your boogies
and he's like okay cool so he goes like
this and the minute goes inside he's
like
ah he starts crying yeah oh because it's
not
it's uncomfortable for adults you know
yeah and then it's the brush size
doesn't change
it's still that big-ass brush before
tiny nostrils you know i always
um i actually had a pretty pleasant
experience with a doctor even with like
needles and everything because uh my mom
worked at a doctor's office in a
dentist's office and like
she used to be a receptionist for like
the medicals oh yeah so every time i
went to one it was like i'm going there
to visit my mom and her friends let's
call me
probably yeah and then i get toys but
then every time i'm in the waiting room
i see
kids with like a [ __ ] toy raptor and
then they're like crying and then like
i'm like why are they crying
it's a scary spot i feel like they could
make it way better it's like cold and
like yeah but if you were going there to
see
like your family member it doesn't feel
scary that's true
right yeah like even if you see the
needle stuff the way that they tell you
i guess like it's like yeah it's gonna
make you better and whatever i don't
know
yeah for every time tyka got shots we
have to trick him because if he sees the
needle he starts like squeezing
and he's like strong we always give him
like okay here's
here's a lollipop you can't eat it until
we count to three
okay because on the three is when the
needle goes into so
okay one two and he goes
so he eats it and then it's like ah but
i feel that i feel so bad i'm like
a trick the thing is like i'm always
like is it like an actual pain that they
feel
or is it just in your mind because i
know adults that are like that but then
i was like i've seen when dogs get shots
yeah and obviously you could trigger dog
way easier but they feel that [ __ ] they
start squirming and they start screaming
yeah oh i think you feel it but it's
i it might be mental because like when i
started taking like steroids when i
first took them
like injections was easy it's easy so
now going to the doctor is like after
like not doing
everything it's like no problem that's
the thing i can't poke myself man
it's scary yeah i remember like daisy
how deep is it when you do
the steroids is that through the veins
no no well if you do a vein it's really
bad so it's just dude like you just
any like large muscle area yeah so i
mean there's different places you could
do but then it's like
um like your butts like your quads
places that have like general like
big masses that was like a little bit
easier yeah speaking of fitness
this episode is brought to you by
oxyclean
max force and i'm saying i'm speaking of
fitness because during the quarantine i
was like oh shoot
i need to up all my nutrients and
and multivitamins so i was making my uh
my performance greens
and i messed up i didn't have it on
tight so the minute i started shaking
green sprayed all over the place and i'm
like oh [ __ ]
what am i gonna do jill's gonna [ __ ]
kill me because i'm also trying to sell
the house right
so i was like oh [ __ ] i got the oxiclean
max force so i knocked on the door i'm
like bam can you bring it to me
and so she brought it to me and uh even
though i only had a little bit left
because i've actually been using it
um i put it all over the carpet you guys
could watch the vlogs i started
scrubbing it like crazy and it all went
out
so the other day i still haven't told
geo that i i'm just gonna find out now
but um i haven't told her that i got it
on the ground but the last three times
she went into the room and she talks i
always look at her eyes and i look at
the ground
she probably saw the vlog i know but
then she hasn't said anything
so shout outs to oxyclean max force for
being able to even clean supplements off
the ground
if you guys don't know what it is it's a
convenient laundry stain remover spray
that tackles the toughest
dried in stains with five types of
strain fighters to remove grease oil
grass
grass blood soil clay food and drink
stains the first time
hell yeah and it dissolves and traps
grease and oil
lifts food stains from fabrics binds to
dirt
and soil to suspend them and rinse them
away it's safe on colors
spray now wash up to seven days later
you've got to try oxyclean max force for
yourself
to work your magic with oxiclean go to
oxyclean.com
maxforce1 to get a coupon for one
dollar off baby thank you oxiclean thank
you max
force for keeping bart not in trouble
during the quarantine i actually worked
out too a couple times oh yeah i just
brought in dumbbells i did like really
light ones with body weight
and then i did some with dumbbells and
it paid off
just a little bit because then i went to
the gym the minute i got or am i trained
in my backyard the minute i got out and
i didn't lose that much strength dude
wait
can we go back to your whole steroid
thing because that just hit me out of
nowhere
and i was like hold on
you guys are talking about it so
nonchalantly like what well the fitness
community a lot of people are on
and i think i've been knowing that
dean's on friday yeah yeah i mean not
now
but i'm saying like when i did it when i
did it and then
i was like i'm like super open about
everything so like if i would take it
i'ma talk about it
um and then i got off but it's illegal
right
yeah yeah it is i mean i mean i smoke
weed you know like but
when it was not legal it's kind of gray
area
because it's one of those things where
like you can kind of get a doctor
to prescribe it yes but it's also like
joe rogan talks about doing uh trt no
like uh
mushrooms and stuff like that but no no
one's gonna go and arrest him for it
he's like i'm just wondering is it it's
it's not like because i keep hearing
that it's illegal i can't get arrested
for her now for taking it years ago but
it is legal
yeah okay unless you get through like a
doctor or something so it's kind of like
getting an antidepressant without
prescription
that's all that's the that's the
legality of it and it's also
and actually i also don't know what the
actual
um legal part of it is at least in
california like i don't know if
it's a controlled substance oh it is so
possession is no good
no yeah yeah you know some things it's
like you can have
like uh back when we was illegal but you
could have the seats
and that was cool remember it was like
it's like the laws are weird so is it
grown is it like made in lab like like
in a
garage lab hopefully that is made in a
proper lab
sometimes it can be made out of a
bathtub you don't you don't know you got
to go through like a private thing
sometimes it's like
you actually get it from like actual
pharmacies and like legit spots yeah
so it all depends on who you get it from
luckily i've when i did it i
got it all like properly okay um but
it's it's kind of like the same thing
where it's like
a cop pulls you over that's probably not
what they're looking for they don't want
to go through all this trouble for that
they'll probably like
either take it it might give you a take
whatever like it might be
but they all take it themselves yeah
yeah i don't even think they'll care i
think they popped open their trunk and
there's like
bags of cocaine like get the [ __ ] off
but if they see like stairways
like get the [ __ ] up
who's your supplier i know can you have
him hit me up so
it was like that and i was just like
super open about it so i talked about
plus i talked about it so i could tell
people why i got off
and why i don't recommend other people
getting oh i know a lot of
cops that work the jails that were
actually on yeah and they had to
because the inmates were on too how do
they get steroids in jail
i don't know through the booty hole dude
there's people in jail that are on tick
tock there's people in jail that are
doing like
crazy [ __ ] i'm like you could get
anything in jail i know man but steroids
is just
it's crazy because i probably pump my
body up with every single drug known to
mankind but i'm afraid of steroids like
crazy
i'm me too i think i'm just scared of
like the effects on the nuts
dude you'll do ecstasy every day and
then [ __ ]
cheese wheeze your brain but you're just
like i don't know about steroids man
what effect on your nuts um well i don't
so
i don't know i feel like um i've heard
of people's nuts not coming back
i've also seen like extreme balding oh
i've seen that a lot
yeah yeah and i've seen people like some
people they get that
that red bloat face remember there's
that guy at our old gym named
and his facebook i was going to explode
we shouldn't say his name
and his face look like an orangutan yeah
so it all depends on like what you take
because there's okay so this is what the
doctors would give you
testosterone then there's maybe some
other mild things that they could give
you
everything after that was developed for
like crazy reasons and they were like yo
this shit's way too strong or like
for like aids patients or like growth is
given to like people like that or people
that aren't underdeveloped and stuff
like that
and then people take that and abuse that
and then there's the stuff that's like
500 times stronger than testosterone
which is like trending stuff
so like taking tests what about stuff do
you do you know what they do like like
when stroll
or all those things are horrible they're
all bad huh yeah because of the stuff
that i heard of when i first started
lifting and getting into fitness
uh this is maybe like 20 years ago it's
like it kind of
shifted it went from steroids and super
bro like as much as possible to now very
scientific approaches to it
and like people program the cycles
exactly so it's like most people i know
that take in smaller amounts
getting better results and not dying
compared to the people that would take
huge amounts because
all these like say huge bodybuilders
that would take a lot of them would take
like a massive amount and some of them
would be like
yo they're taking way too much and you
see other people not being able to walk
they're dead now they're in like
young ages and like you lift like
something and you're out of breath and
then your [ __ ] face is red but it's
like
depending on how you do it and this is
not like telling people to get on and do
it safely but
there are always safer ways of doing uh
whatever you want to do do you think
people should try it
the thing is like it's where people are
like oh you get this [ __ ] huge
like feeling you don't you don't feel
anything you just feel like stronger
over time the recovery maybe is a little
bit faster
but in terms of it once you get off uh
you pretty much lose
all of that like all the stuff that came
like say like if you get bigger
shoulders
from like the shoulder um or like being
on steroids like that unnatural shoulder
you'll lose that too yeah you know like
the pictures of like vitor belfort
before and after like uh alyssa over him
all those people
like those like the pre before ufc was
getting tested everyone was like this
and then the after pictures everyone's
like yeah they look
not so full yeah so you lose it all damn
that's crazy man i don't know
it's funny because i'll snort some horse
tranquilizer but when it comes to that
steroids man that [ __ ] scares the [ __ ]
out of me
it is kind of scary but then it's also
it's a gamble of do you want superhuman
powers
no it's not like spider-man where it's
night and day but if you put in the work
over six months you can be like totally
transform what you're able to do
i think it's like girls don't even like
those big ass guys
from my experience it's not for the
girls it's for the curls
i don't know man i i heard pcp gives you
super hey
human strength yeah you can just do pcp
all day no man i don't know i can't even
touch drugs anymore just nothing
it's like i think i'm just too scared of
any of that [ __ ] like even caffeine i'm
like oh i gotta
chill this is too much man do you smoke
weed here in there a little bit yeah
that's what i'll do but not like how i
used to before like
i don't even do bond grips um maybe i'll
like
share a joint with someone or like maybe
i'll take a hit out of a pipe but
like before when i used to smoke weed
you know like you're just trying to like
do one of these like let me [ __ ] milk
this [ __ ] to the roof yeah
you're trying to get
[ __ ] up i haven't smoked in years but
then uh on thanksgiving uh it was like
uh
four of us you did it for the pilgrims
i was like [ __ ] it like they're like
i'll take this i'm like nah i don't know
did you get a turkey bunk
oh that would be sick just smoke out the
turkey turkey's [ __ ]
they gave me a uh 10 milligrams and
they're like take it like you're a big
guy i was like i've done 70 before and
that was a like a
horrible horrible experience i just
thought it was like one gummy that was
70. so i took it so this was 10. so i
was like fine
i take it and then he's all right cool
and he takes his and puts on a plate and
starts cutting up into four pieces
i'm like what are you doing and he looks
like he goes nobody takes ten and i'm
like what the
[ __ ] he's like oh you're a big guy you
can handle it
worst experience the worst thing of my
life was it like
psychedelic like what was just weak no
but like was it
was it more of a i just get
uncomfortable were you like uh
leonardo dicaprio and wolf on wall
street is coming out getting trying to
get to his lambo no
but we did like none of us could hold a
conversation for more than like 10
seconds
dying laughing the whole time we played
mafia with three people
with three
so who was the moderator there's only
one uh so it was four of us
uh it was one that was the moderator
it was so [ __ ] funny the mafia wakes
up recognize the other mafia he's like
just me
so no you know it's only one person you
wake up and you go okay like okay say i
point on joe right and then joe wakes up
he's the nerve
he has to point out one of us because he
doesn't know which one was the mafia
right and then uh then there's only one
civilian so there's no cop
there's no cop yeah oh [ __ ] so it's only
one round so
basically the game is to convince the
civilian oh so there's one nurse
one mafia yeah and one civilian yeah and
then so you wake up and then we talk and
we're like oh what are you so the
civilians
so it's the mafia's job to like
basically
manipulate and pretend they're a
civilian yeah so say i wake up and i'm
off it i'm like i'm civilian but you're
sibling
and then he won't know because he's a
nurse yeah so it's between us and now
it's like who do you believe
so i'm planning to i'm like do you i
love those that sounds so stupid but
sounds fun
cause you gotta pin them against each
other it was so stupid but it was hella
fun
plus we're hella high
you